comme chacun le sait l'une des missions
essentielles du sénat est la
représentation des collectivités locales
des collectivités territoriales
notamment les communes les mairies au
l'essentiel de mon parcours politique
depuis plus de 20 ans était de me
consacrer aux services publics locaux
aujourd'hui je me rends compte que pour
être plus pertinent pour être plus
efficace pour avoir plus d'influencé au
niveau des sphères de décision qui se
situe à paris
le mode à part le moteur est
incontournable c'est pour cette raison
d'ailleurs je brigue l'espace son mandat
sénatorial a pas pour venir le faire en
plus mais j'avais en profiter pour
distribuer les missions de je m'occupe
actuellement mais j'envisage de servir
de relais à ceux qui prendront la relève
aussi bien au niveau du monde
hospitalier qu'au niveau de l'eau pour
servir de relais auprès des associations
donc pour résumer mon pare aux services
publics locaux dans les communes en
particulier mon seul mandat électif et
aujourd'hui c'est le sénat qui me
permettra d'être plus efficace et pour
défendre d'une manière générale les
tirer de la martinique et des
martiniquais